Bonjour curieuses et curieux !
et voilà, c'est la fin de l'été...
j'espère que vous avez pu faire des
châteaux de sable
et vous balader tranquillement
le long de la plage sur le sable humide
mais avez vous pensé à regarder ce qu'il se passait sous vos pieds ?
Le sable c'est ce qu'on appelle un
milieu granulaire
c'est à dire qu'il est constitué d'un
grand nombre de grains solides,
secs ou baignant dans un liquide.
et ce type de milieu, comme les dunes de sable
ou les poudres compactées des cachets d'aspirine,
a des propriétés très étonnantes et très étudiées
car il peut réagir tantôt comme un solide,  comme un liquide ou un gaz.
Des chercheurs de Marseille ont ainsi voulu mieux comprendre
le comportement de ces milieux face à un choc.
Voici le type de résultats qu'ils ont
obtenu :
si si c'est bien le même milieu !
une cuve remplie d'eau avec des petits
grains dans laquelle on envoie... une bille.
Alors... à votre avis d'où vient la
différence ?
Un indice ... ça.
Bon, je vous explique.
Pour préparer cette expérience,
les chercheurs disposent dans une cuve
de petites sphères de verre de moins
d'un millimètre = les grains.
Puis ils remplissent d'eau pour mettre les grains en suspension,
et ensuite ils évacuent l'eau superflue.
Voilà comment on obtient l'image de gauche.
Mais dans l'image de droite,
les chercheurs ont frappé la cuve
pour tasser les grains du milieu.
Non il ne frappent pas comme moi je plante des clous dans mes meubles ikea...
Chaque coup est bien étalonné,
de manière à connaître exactement
le degré de tassement du milieu.
Et on appelle ça le "taux de compaction".
Donc la différence entre ces deux expériences
c'est que à gauche on a un milieu meuble
(et je ne parle pas d'ikea)
et à droite on a un milieu compact.
Et le plus étonnant c'est qu'il y a seulement
4 % de différence de compaction
entre ces deux expériences.
Maintenant que se passe-t-il pour que
l'on observe un comportement
si différent entre les deux images ?
Lors de l'impact, le milieu va se déformer
sous la pression de l'objet qui arrive
ça implique de faire bouger le liquide qui
est présent entre les grains
Dans le milieu, à l'arrivée de l'objet,
les grains vont se réorganiser, se tasser...
et éjecter le liquide vers l'extérieur,
ce qui repousse les grains.
Le milieu se comporte alors comme un liquide.
A l'inverse quand le milieu est très tassé,
l'impact de l'objet va déformer
l'empilement des grains.
Ils s'écartent les uns des autres,
ce qui provoque une aspiration de l'eau.
Sous l'objet, cette aspiration plaque les grains entre eux et rigidifie le milieu.
Et dans ce cas le milieu répond alors aux chocs
comme un solide
En fait c'est comme quand on marche sur
le sable :
ça devient dur sous la plante des pieds
et ça fait des bourrelets sur les côtés.
Ainsi ce qui va déterminer le
comportement d'un milieu granulaire face à un choc,
c'est la préparation initiale
de l'empilement de ces grains
meuble = réaction liquide
tassé = réaction solide
Mais pour un même empilement plus le
liquide a du mal à circuler entre les
grains plus la rigidité du milieu est
grande et c'est ce que les chercheurs
ont tenté de montrer avec une deuxième
série d'expériences
d'abord en tassant le milieu autant que
précédemment mais en utilisant des
grains de plus grand diamètre et là il
observe que le milieu est moins rigide
car il ya plus d espace entre les grains
pour que le liquide circulent
puis avec les mêmes grain passé mais en
remplaçant l'eau par un liquide plus
visqueux et là le milieu est plus solide
car cette fois le liquide a plus de mal
à se déplacer
donc en changeant seulement la
préparation du système grain plus
liquides
les chercheurs ont montré qu'ils
pouvaient retrouver l'ensemble des
comportements des milieux granulaires et
en plus expliqué certains risques
naturels la formation de cratères la
liquéfaction des sols
ces travaux pourraient aider au
développement de nouveaux types de
matériaux pour les gilet pare-balles par
exemple voilà donc vous pourrez vous la
péter désormais à l'apéro en expliquant
pourquoi les cacahuètes peuvent se
comporter comme un solide ou comme un
liquide donc ne minimisons pas l'intérêt
de cette recherche car ce résultat c'est
du solide
si vous aussi vous aimez les cacahuètes
abonnez vous